madame monsieur bonsoir ce devait être
la routine ce fut le drame 45 secondes
après le décollage
la navette américaine challenger
exploser en plein vol elle sait
pulvérisé dans une gerbe de flammes
il y avait sept astronautes à bord selon
la nasa il n'y a pas de survivant avant
de revenir sur les détails sur les
explications de cette catastrophe
tout de suite les images de l'accident
et des secondes qui l'ont précédé avec
hervé brusini il avait fait très froid
ici à cap canaveral sens dans la nuit
ce petit matin le pas de tir était en
partie gelé deux heures de retard pour
le lancement
11h38 heure locale 13h38 17h38 pardon
chez nous le décompte commence
nous sommes à 25 secondes du départ et
tout est normal quinze secondes du
départ système de pression durant klein
cher n'est en mode automatique les
ordinateurs
interroge 440 fois par seconde et moteur
allumage du moteur principal
à l'image des deux fusées les booster
qui sont part et d'autre de l'énorme
réservoir c'est le décollage super à
terre ils sont admiratifs
très rapidement la navette atteint les 3
4 kilomètres par seconde
et puis vient la réduction progressive
de la puissance 94% 84% que 65 la
navette va pivoter sur elle-même et tout
est parfaitement normal comment que le
patron du centre de la nasa
bientôt les caméras du sol vont quitter
la navette la prise de vue va être
relayée par avion mais soudain la
navette totalement pulvérisées
une partie du public je me comprends
l'une des deux fusées d'appoint continue
une course désormais folle mais comment
tout cela s'est il réellement passé
revoyant les images des flammèches
apparaissent à la base du moteur
principal et puis très vite tout a
explosé ce soir à cap canaveral pour le
moment la consternation prend encore le
pas sur la volonté de comprendre